we award with your host Jerry Jon and
straight out of schmoeville Christian
Awards
hey people and my crew welcome back to
the you reviewers Movie Awards this is
episode three we're having a lot of fun
and I'm fully recovered from my bender
and schmoeville if you saw that in the
last episode if you haven't go check it
out but our next category is most
underrated film and here to present it
is Jonathan Paula from movie night
thanks Jeremy for those who don't know
me my name is Jonathan Paula and besides
producing is it a good idea to microwave
this I also host movie night a weekly
show where I feature three scripted film
reviews viewer comments sketches fancy
graphics and well you should go check
out anyway I'm here tonight to present
the award for most underrated film of
2012 some truly great movies in this
group that for whatever reason many of
us overlooked for some context I'll
include my quick five word review for
each and the nominees are arbitrage
traditionally forgettable but
intriguingly entertaining end of watch
enjoyable bittersweet realism
distracting presentation the grey
exhilarating nail-biting adventure
thriller The Perks of Being a Wallflower
transcendently poignant lasting and
relatable Seven Psychopaths maniacally
fun dialogue haphazard story and the you
reviewer award goes to
the perks of being a wallflower
big congrats this coming-of-age teen
drama on being the most underrated film
of 2012
unfortunately the cast and crew are
unable to be here tonight so I will
gladly accept the award on their behalf
I feel infinite thank you
well that does it for me so now back to
the studio thank you John and I gotta
say if there's someone I want to present
Perks of Being a Wallflower for being
the most underrated film is the guy who
has the convictions in life to put a ps3
in a microwave and burn it to hell and I
know you're on pins and needles right
now waiting for the next category to
present it I'm gonna hand it over to
flick pick next up is my personal
favorite category it's the yin to the
yang these are the guys in the movies
who go in they blow stuff up the wreck
they pillage its Best Villain and it's
presented by Jack and Dean Dean we're
here to present the Award for Best
Villain here on the nomination Tom Hardy
for bein with The Dark Knight Rises
Javier Bardem for silver in Skyfall guy
pays for the questionable haircut in
pretty evil there's no be more evil than
a sense of Pi you know DiCaprio for
candy in Django Unchained because again
there's nothing scarier is that candy
with a k' candy hot and Tom Hiddleston
born Tom Hiddleston
okay stop good Austin's been donated for
Loki for the Avenger so those are the
nominations and the winner is I've got
my little drum again I got it last year
yeah I'm gonna do the drum roll Owen are
you guys yeah what did you steal my
trough oh boy this is a new one okay and
the winner is
I think sorry I put it said it already
help you I'll buy them for Skyfall thank
you I thought this set is pretty
appropriate for the earth yeah look
you've got the white and black backdrops
good bad light and dark we're not racist
though are we
no we're open-minded good bad yeah
that's what young go and change Tommy
yeah yeah all the time yeah I think you
told us that not one race is the villain
but all races the human race thank you
jack and Dean funny as always in
presenting arguably the most difficult
category in the entire you reviewers
Movie Awards Best Villain there were
like seven to ten that we're awesome you
have to pick one and it is javier bardem
with his creepy job I like the setting
yeah it's a little different right like
we're not in the you reviewer studio
anymore my hair is a little longer like
I just filmed this today and the you
reviewer segment was filmed a while ago
yeah funny story about that okay in a
world of technical difficulties that
happen with the thing like this some of
the video segments were corrupted and
absolute [ __ ] we couldn't use them
no one's fault except maybe Skynet
because something like this tells me
that Skynet has now become self-aware
and is out to destroy the you reviewers
movie award so we will not go down
without a fight my friends I will film
you reviewer segments here and with the
help of my other presenter friends were
we're gonna pull through this [ __ ] and
don't worry it's just episode 3 episode
4 we'll be back to you reviewers isn't
this the smells get the day off to go
hunt down the machines that did this and
for our next segment as villains are the
yin to the yang the heroes are the yang
to the end to present best hero is the
guy with the biggest biceps and movie
reviewing jon Flickinger the flick pin
take it away bane
first hey there guys my name is John I'm
with the flick pic channel and I'm here
to present best hero of 2012 he's the
big green killing machine and he almost
OD don't gamma-rays Incredible Hulk he's
a billionaire playboy with a great
goatee Ironman his parents are dead and
he loves dressing up like a bat Batman
he's breaking the chains and he's going
to Candyland Django he's a double O 7
agent and he likes it shaken not stirred
James Bond and the winner is I see
that's my badass announcer voice not
very good but I'm working on it and the
best year of 2012 is okay y'all let you
announce it of 2012 is what in all
fairness the man almost did die for his
beloved city and I remember when Gotham
is ashes you have my permission to
subscribe to the flip-it channel sorry
I'm late by the way thanks bane I'm
gonna give a quick shout-out to Alfred
because without you I just be an orphan
and I want to give a big thanks to all
my fans because without you I wouldn't
be Batman and there we are the Batman
who knew except probably everybody oh
wait this makes me think Javier Bardem
from Skyfall best villain Batman from
The Dark Knight Rises best hero so does
that mean James Bond would actually
break Bane or does that mean Batman
would actually beat the [ __ ] out of
Javier Bardem from Skyfall I don't know
all I know is I can't argue with the
wind a lot of tough ones in both
categories this year and next up we have
the category of best visual effects
visual effects do not make a movie by
any means but they do help if the movie
really calls for it sorry Michael Bay it
doesn't make a movie to present best
visual effects is Mike from belated
media he may be presenting best visual
effects but don't let it fool you that
beard is real no CGI here my friends
take it away Mike georges milies would
be pleased right now when he got his
hands on a camera his visual tricks were
the foundation for movie magic and the
category of visual effects celebrates
that ability for a movie to transport us
and show us things that we would never
be able to experience in any other way
until sometime in the future when we can
all live in Holograms but since that day
is not now we celebrate these films for
their technical achievements the
nominees are Life of Pi digitally
creating Richard Parker and a slew of
other animals Prometheus for showing us
the engineers and all the other alien
life-forms
so Dark Knight Rises which destroyed a
football stadium in the name of golf
levels are among the hobbit for allowing
us to go inside of goblin caves and meet
Gollum and the Avengers which modelled
the Hulk after Mark Ruffalo and the
winner of Best Visual Effects is
sorry guys I had to draw attention out
just a little bit the winners Life of Pi
in congratulations to you for creating a
spectacular visual sensation for our
cones and rods well I'm done here back
to you Life of Pi I love the fact that
Life of Pi won this category because
there are a lot of visual effects in
Life of Pi but it's still used as a
means a tool to tell the story well done
Angley that's how you do it but hanging
out with the tiger on a boat you've
never done that I have what is that
weird so before we get to our last
category Best Director in Episode three
I would say we're gonna switch gears a
bit we're not really switching gears
we're going to celebrate the gear we're
in new up-and-coming movie reviewers are
popping up every day on YouTube doing
what they love they're realizing that
hey I love talking about movies I'm
gonna set up a camera and I'm gonna do
that and I love seeing that you guys
keep doing it and to celebrate that fact
with us is a young and up-and-coming
movie reviewer named Mothman Jones you
look at this guy you see young me young
schmoes young us young all of us so
here's Mothman Jones I got a I got a
pocketful of sunshine I got a no-no but
a holy the hell you guys doing get out
of the way I think it won't for the you
reviewers Awards your request denied
what do we have to fear you had the fear
the fact that you two were ants and I'm
the poop
oh my god the brakes oh hey guys I'm
John Massey oh also known as Mothman
Jones on YouTube and welcome to your
viewers Awards this is a fascinating
asset because anybody doesn't just
concern movies could pick up a camera
and speak about it for about five or six
minutes and turn it to a hobby and then
turn that hobby into possibly something
worth more and even though I've only
been on YouTube for a year I've
accomplished and I've met so many people
and for anybody out there whose might be
perhaps depressed or not satisfied from
where they're at I'm telling you guys
don't give up get a good work ethic just
work hard and stay consistent eventually
you will find success I'm speaking on
behalf of old little guys out there
including myself
aha to quote rocky himself it's not
about how hard you hit it's about how
hard you can get hit and keep moving
forward back to Jeremy and the schmoes
back in the studio oh wow thank you moth
man like I said I love seeing this I
love seeing people do what they love
like David from Prometheus said big
things have small beginnings
well you said it buddy and so our last
category for episode 3 is Best Director
I'm sorry to Josh mccoon guy you
remember him our one eye director of the
year reviewers Movie Awards he was not
nominated for Best Director this year
but then again neither was Spielberg
because life's just that unfair I guess
and to present this award was going to
be yours truly but there is someone out
there who got incriminating photos of me
when I was on my bender and you
reviewers episode two so through a
little bit of blackmail I now give you
Best Director for those of you who have
been subscribed to me for a while you
will remember this guy he needs no
introduction
take it away buddy
first director that's right no Jeremy
here just your old friend [ __ ] [ __ ] you
Jeremy taking over your channel boy what
you've been staring at is pretty boy
face for the past video don't act like
you mission I'm here to give you the
nominations and winner for Best Director
a 2012 and nominees is Kathryn Bigelow
for zero dark thirty
Joss Whedon for the Avengers David
O'Russell for silver linings silver
linings playbook Quentin Tarantino for
dead Django Unchained and Ben Affleck
for Argo [ __ ] yourself
in the winner is Quentin Tarantino for
Django Unchained
congratulations Tarantino great script
great characters even though I'm pretty
sure you blew up my great-grandpappy
with that dentist truck but I'm pretty
sure if Jeremy Jones were here right now
he would say it is a well-deserved win
spot having an absolutely ridiculous
accent he wins the award for director I
loved jag I was hoping just wait for the
Avengers would get more loved but Q
target against you you gotta give it up
to Tarantino you great director
unapologetic director terrible
Australian accent and kills it as a
pedophile I'm from dusk till dawn that
is range well Jamie just want to thank
you for having the schmoes on your
channel it's Paul Hogan apparently it
sound like Terrance and Phillip yeah you
sound like Dick Van Dyke watch a Mary
Poppins well it's better than his accent
so anyway thank you for having us good
job I'd like to thank you guys for
coming out I'd like to thank you all for
watching the year reviewers Movie Awards
this has been episode 3 you can find
episode 1 on my channel 2 on their
Channel and number 4 is coming on their
channel go check that out we're here for
us but we're also here for the fans and
if the fans want the punch
and if or confession or saying that each
side wasn't Skynet that screwed up that
footage it was me pushing on your hard
drive
he's doing my part to sabotage you
various movie awards but it looks like
y'all just trucking on get vine life is
so unfair I'm gonna go watch a dick
swinging Bruno